boy you are a walking mood board aren't
you yes
oh my god you get me you see me
andy first of all i cannot thank you
enough for doing this my pleasure you
are someone
that i truly admire
um i have a lot of questions about live
because we're going to be live yes
we need to talk drew why did you want to
do live um
i live is so exciting i mean the fun
thing about live is
that you you all you
actually can get away with more being
live
if you make a mistake it's like we're
live and guess what
we're really live we didn't just go back
and fix that so
i love the spontaneity of live and i
love sometimes it just goes it all goes
to hell
but um that to me is the thing that
people
respond to the most and i lean into
you know so we're not perfect i think
there's so many kind of shiny floor
shows
that seem perfect and nothing ever goes
wrong and so
life isn't that way so i think live lets
you
be capture a real moment and i like to
do that
i am the most imperfect person so okay
great really embraced what you just said
yes but it's funny because i've never
wanted to do theater
because and i'm sure my family does a
rotisserie churn in the grave every time
exactly they're like why right right
right
you should be on the boards darling
right right but
i love in film that if you do make a
mistake you do get a second chance i
love the idea that if it's a
great morning in america you're gonna
say it's a great morning america if it's
a rough morning you may say it's a rough
morning but we're gonna make it great
so at least some acknowledgement of
what's going on in the ether i think is
really cool when the show first got
picked pitched to me over a year ago
it was gonna be live and then they
changed that and even our pilot was
everything was set for a tape show and
then
i begged in 2020 i said i
i don't know how to do this show not
live well can i give you a
a red flag i'm dying for a red flag
okay here's the deal drew barrymore
please andy cohen are a glorious
rushing river of words
okay now you are going to be
spinning plates on live television
you got to make the river of words a
trickle
you know what i mean i mean you need to
condensed man are you working on that
um i think because
of 2020 yes and the nature of the world
at
every minute our show has basically been
possible or not possible yes yeah right
right um
so i've tried to live in a state of
going on and
on and persevering and figuring out how
to be
technologically advanced meet the moment
um be innovative and
yet there is a part of you until you get
that
real go right and we just got like
our real go we've been in a complete
purgatory okay
and now it's so official and happening
like
nothing's going to happen i think in the
world that's going to stop this
train right on september 14th so
that part of it is really landing with
me for the first time
okay so my question was are you working
on uh condensing your thoughts
into bits and i didn't do with that just
now you did not
mm-hmm okay so i'm telling you this is a
growth opportunity the other piece of
advice that i could say
is kelly ripa told me this actually you
think oh my god that was so great
or you think oh my god that was so bad
it's never as amazing as you thought it
was and it's never as bad as you thought
it was
and the other thing is you have to do it
all again tomorrow
so it's a constant growth so you're
measured not
by show but by the whole cumulative
experience or the vibe that you're
giving people you know
i think i'm really bad at the rearview
mirror in life i'll make a decision
and then ask myself 20 times over was it
the right one
but i don't have a big review mirror
when it comes to work i'm much more
about the next thing oh good that's a
really healthy vibe
i just have such positive feelings about
your show because
i think we as a nation are in a place
where we're looking for an escape and
we're looking for good news
or positivity and you're a good news
positive lady that a lot of people love
and connect with
and so i think for that reason
this is going to be this is going to go
well
i'm utterly flawed too well that's good
but that's why we relate to you also
you know we've seen you since you were
gertie we've seen you
on your highs and on your lows you know
but we want to run up to the pitcher's
mound
and kiss you uh because you've never
been kissed
you know and ironically i i
i just you know what's interesting to me
is and i told my daughter this yesterday
when you know you are capable of change
though
it is one of the ultimate senses of
freedom
because you know you're not stuck so i
do know that whatever i battle with
in life i always even if it takes
way too long i will get there
to fix it yeah be honest about it yeah
and mo and move forward and look forward
to the next thing i have to conquer
yeah yeah you're a closer thank you i've
never heard that before
you are it's what's interesting is that
if i look at your life story
and i think wow you know there have been
some major speed bumps in your
life the triumphs are what you look at
and you can't
that's what makes you a closer work has
kept me accountable
my whole life right i've been a good
girl like with work yes you can't have
had the career that you
have and be as diversified as you are
if you're a complete by the way but it
was on your show
and i drank too much and i have never
forgiven myself
nor will i ever forgive myself really
because
whatever personal thing i do nobody
sees it even though i'm an imperfect
person and i tout that
and i've had that liberty since i was a
kid
because it was all out there yeah and it
was either
boohoo about it or say
god it's sort of redeeming to not have
to pretend to be perfect
but i really want to apologize to you
because
i really like uh i just
i will never let that happen again oh
god well so sorry you know
i'm used to people being over served on
my show
and so i don't even have a totally clear
memory of it
but you don't need to apologize to me
for being over served on my show that
that is
that happens oh god you're a great club
of people
you have every kind of person on your
show everyone has come to play from
meryl streep to oprah
and then you have to be the un
ambassador with the greatest
skill set you know in your reunions
and what you have done is my favorite
thing in the world
you have mixed tones
i love you for getting that because i am
all about high and low
and that is my entire goal in everything
that i'm doing
yes i see it crystal clear thank you
i admire it thank you and i applaud it
thank you and that
i think is the mastery of your show well
i think that there's
no one thing anymore you know what i
mean so
people view lisa vanderpump and
helen mirren they're like oh yeah no i
love to watch lisa vanderpump on tv and
i love to watch helen mirren in a movie
like why can't i see both of those
people in the same place
i think that's what life is today
you know it's it used to be just these
are the stars
or this is who's on and i try to be a
representation of what's
really happening in culture right now on
my show
i mean i just love that so
much and i've always said variety is the
spice of life
yeah people have different moods and you
have to be vast
in the way that you reach people because
i just think that the wider net you cast
and you have an all-ages party and
everyone's invited
yeah i want to bounce around i have a
lot of different
genres of life that i care about
i want to figure out everything in the
self-improvement category
but comedy is my medicine yeah and i'm a
pop culture
junkie yeah um but i want to also have
very
timeless discussions because at some
point
they're going to be relevant right boy
you are a walking mood board aren't you
yes oh my god you get me you see me
you are i mean it's just all there the
thing
that you do which is really my goal and
i think
very true to who i am is i feel like you
know everybody too
but you're not smug about it and that is
where i turn off as an audience member
there's an enthusiasm that is necessary
and exciting about i'm with someone i
admire it doesn't matter if we have
history or i know you
i'm still coming at it with an
enthusiasm yeah
and when people come at it with that
insider baseball smugness i can't stand
it
yeah i can't either but i mean you know
look on the flip side i think there are
a lot of people
who think i'm a disgusting name dropper
so you know it's about doing the dance
you know i i will say i think you come
off
like you're having so much fun but
you're smart
and none of it seems like an accident
because you're
very behind the scenes on everything
right yes you're doing it yes
you're the puppet master the puppet and
everything in between
yeah and so that's how what i take away
as an audience member
thank you thank you for making me want
to be a better person in so many
categories
wow thank you i'm going to keep up with
all of these lists
keep you posted in real time about all
of them time your
rushing river conversations yeah yeah
there's a book called i know how she
does it where a woman
equates basically every moment in life
to an excel spreadsheet
of time oh wow it's the scariest read
you need xanax with it
right because i never thought life was
that short
and i knew it metaphorically but not in
seconds
minutes and hours um so i'm going to
start using that principle
good or else you're going to be kicked
off the air
not kicked off the air but bumped off
you know what i'm saying
i do thank you andy thank you drew
you